you are toxic
I made it this far right
what's the point
Toby why don't you open your present no
no no no no no no no no no this hey hey
hey this might not be what I think
that I don't even know is in there
because there are a lot of presents in
my car and I don't know which is which
suck on this
what the hell is that Michael that's
what do you mean Michael
that's not even my handwriting hey
what the hell is going on here
who thought it would be hysterical to
give Toby a rock for his going away gift
you didn't no you made me rap it I
thought it was over the line
how could you give up my diary like that
I had to I'm sorry but I need to win
this we need to win this how'd you even
find it you keep it under my side of the
mattress I don't like the lump I'm
really upset about this all right I
stole your diary and gave it to my
lawyer you emailed a topless photo of me
to everyone in our company I'm looking
at a photo right now
and I'm telling you it could be in Maxim
oh no
okay well
check this out
I'm sending you
some email
you got it what no I
check it again hit refresh
okay wait a second I sent it to you
at Packer Dunder mifflin.com
oh
I just got it from somebody else
wow
this is hot damn
how do I get you out of this picture
I have a few things to say to you and
please don't interrupt I wasn't going to
interview you do a lot so just don't
thank you I know that I haven't always
treated you the way that you for
whatever reason feel you deserve to be
treated
but I want to marry you Kelly Kapoor
Maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but someday
and probably barf
better
the cutest button
button worked up quite a sweat is
removing all of sprinkles organs right
now and sending them to the lab
I am a farmer Angela what does that mean
okay when a farmer sees an animal that
is in pain that has no quality of life
that has no utility a farmer does what
city Folk don't have the stomach to do
hey do you uh
do you like the Jamie Kennedy experiment
yeah and punked and all that kind of
stuff okay
um you were going to be my accomplice
just go along with it okay all right
just follow my lead don't pimp me all
right come in
so uh corporate just said that I don't
want to oh thank you Pam can you come in
here for a sec
let's have a seat I was gonna call you
in anyway
um you know Ryan
as you know
there's going to be downsizing and you
have made my life
so much easier
in that I am going to have to let you go
first
what why
well theft
stealing stealing
um what am I supposed to have stolen
Post-it notes
Post-it notes what are those worth like
50 cents 50 cents yeah you steal a
thousand Post-it notes at 50 cents a
piece and you know you've made a profit
margin you know go run us out of
business Pam are you serious
yeah
um I can't believe this I mean I've
never even stolen as much as a paper
clip and now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
We're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh did I just clean
out your desk
I'm sorry
human ex Punk
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around see okay he was in on it he was
my accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were showing the new guy
around kind of kind of giving him the
feel of the place
so
you God you were we totally got you
you're a jerk
well I don't know about that
there are a lot of different ways to get
revenge I've had great success by
defecating in a paper bag that's it on
the very effective I've been on the
receiving end of that quite a few times
no no no it has to be physical I want
this person to suffer what about a knee
capping no you're not helping Trevor yes
and kneecapping could work
in prison you are somebody's
oh and you you my friend would be the
bell of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap Michael please
Albert
hey uh I uh you know heard there's a
rumor going around about you used to
have a crush on Pam oh no no no no no
it's it's cool because I know you're a
good guy and I know that that Crush
ended a long time ago so you know
cool right
yeah nope yeah definitely you know I'm
it's great with me because we're glad
she has a friend at work she can get
through the day with
you know when she gets home yeah I like
talking to her too I guess there are
just some people who
you stay together with when you transfer
and some people you don't and that's
just the way it is
and I can be mature about that
oh
[Laughter]
surprise it was part of the party
pretty funny huh you think this is funny
I don't
but someday I think we will laugh about
this
when we tell our kids
oh
okay that's nice
[Music]
to make things simpler for DeAngelo I
just without lying strongly implied that
I'm Kelly supervisor it's not even that
much of a stretch she pretty much does
whatever I say hey Kelly Kapoor if I
don't have those call logs on my desk
we're just gonna have to evaluate your
future of the company
sure thing Mr Howard oh glad he's not my
boss
you're the best thank you
oh thank you Pam and I hope you are as
gracious during
this next part
Helene once again you are a wonderful
person and you have lived a great life
and I envy it and I want it someday but
just in the future
you need somebody who who understands
your references who is kafka-esque I've
never I don't know him
there's another woman
and her name is Italy and skydiving
and bungee jumping okay so and I want
kids and you unfortunately have already
completed that part of your journey down
there Michael it's not my decision it's
mother nature and mother has very strict
rules about Fritz
fertility I don't get it how could she
be sleeping with you this whole time
only sleep with me twice
what what
she's sleeping with you I'm a fiance
she said she was only sleeping with me
do you think that'll ever be us no
what is wrong with you why did you even
bring me here tonight
I don't know
let's break up
well what
what kind of music are you into Peter uh
I like all kinds of music Gabe really
all kinds she likes songs of hate
written by the white Knights of the Ku
Klux Klan are you even hearing this if
he didn't even say that he's not a very
sophisticated man I mean he can't use
chopsticks so you
Aaron I've been to Japan I know how to
use chopsticks so well
come back
one night
I don't want you to show I wasted two
years of my life
real clear that Chopsticks is not the
measure of a man
why don't you say at the beginning this
isn't really going that well
all right all right yes that is a
legitimate question does making Aaron
and Pete feel bad make me feel better
yeah it does